well they're all pretty memorable you
know the first one is always the one
that you don't even know what to expect
though the film was Titanic and of
course Titanic wed about everything that
night it was just a thrill my mom and
dad were in the audience and so it was
very special for them and the Oscar goes
to Robert Legato Mark lasso Thomas El
Fisher and Michael caner for Titanic the
other one that was really memorable for
me too is Yugo the second time because I
was expecting not to win and my children
who were young when we did Titanic were
at home now I brought them to the
Academy Awards giving them the whole
speech of we're not going to win so
don't worry about it so enjoy the night
and you go to the Governor's Ball and
just soak it all in and do not worry
about me cuz I'm fine I want an Oscar
I'm delighted then the film started win
like everything that was sort of
visually oriented and it was like I
don't know maybe something will happen
and then we won and the Oscar goes to
Hugo Rob legado Jos Williams Ben grman
and Alex Henning and my kids were just
like over the moon where it was like
something that it's too good to be true
and I was really kind of audle when I
went on stage cuz I wasn't expecting to
win well I didn't expect this uh I know
it's a I wasn't really prepared for it I
had to wing it when I went up there and
and it was great to see Martin scors and
I'm how lucky I am just to do that to
thank Martin scors at the Academy Awards
literally couldn't be happier that it
turned out like won the millionaire
lottery ticket so when Jungle Book
happened too it was like you know
lightning doesn't generally strike three
times and the Oscar goes to the Jungle
Book Robert again thrilled to death to
hear your name mentioned especially for
everybody because you feel very generous
and very humbled by the fact that you
were singled out to get this a pretty
great prize have to
say